I have determined that it is time to
officially recognize Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel while previous
presidents have made this a major
campaign promise they failed to deliver
today I am delivering Clinton promised
to do it Bush promised to do it
Obama promised to do it Trump actually
did it and it took a lot of guts to make
this move much of the Islamic world is
warning of severe unrest in some are
even calling for bloodshed in
retaliation for that move just as the
administration tries to revive the
Mideast peace process who better to tell
us what this all means then former
Secretary of Defense Don Rumsfeld he's
the author of a new memoir of his time
in the Ford administration called when
the center held Gerald Ford and the
rescue of the American presidency mr.
secretary it's great to see you I
haven't seen you in a while thanks for
stopping by tonight
I want to start with the big news of the
day the president's decision to move the
capital of Israel to Jerusalem why is
everybody so upset about the timing
given the fact that this has basically
been on the books since 1995 was a huge
bipartisan support most presidents all
the presents I could think of said that
they were going to do it and they didn't
well it I guess the reason it's an issue
is because there are countries around
the world that would prefer that it had
not been done it's a no brainer it's the
right thing to do president Trump made
the right decision he was stepped up and
did it it's inevitable that there will
be some criticism about it but I just
can't imagine any country in the world
that doesn't believe that they have the
right to have their capital where they
want it here's some of the criticism
that you mentioned put up the fullscreen
Egypt says it would complicate Middle
East matters jordan says potentially
dangerous repercussions Palestinians say
dangerous consequences Saudi Arabia our
ally in the region detrimental to the
peace process turkey says it threatens
to sever its ties with Israel so the
pressure being ramped up both in the
Middle East and in elite circles here in
Washington in Europe and in Europe a
Merkel says it's bad mais Theresa May
says it's bad the Pope weighed in saying
we should keep the status quo is
President Trump out there the man alone
on this no there are a lot of people who
recognize there that it's a rational
thing to do and it's the right thing to
do in my view and I think most of those
countries will get over it I think they
probably have constituencies that feel
that they don't want Israel to be a part
of that world and the vast majority of
the people the world feel differently
they do agree that Israel has a right to
exist and that it should be a part of
that region and that countries are
inevitably going to side where they want
their cattle the point is they think
that Trump is losing the bargaining chip
into that I said well we've been trying
that what the bargain hasn't really gone
that well no I agree I think it's it's
not surprising to me that all the
countries you mentioned have an
understandable need to vent modestly but
it'll go away
if something happens more terrorism
attacks on embassies do you see a
blowback on President Trump like you
provoked this you push this you pushed
it when you didn't need to you're a
wrecking ball mr. chaos that's the line
from the American media many many in the
American media today that this is just
more Trump chaos well I don't see it
that way at all it seems to me that the
president made the right decision he
stepped up and did it it's inevitable
that there'll be people who don't like
it and will make noise about it but the
idea that it would lead to a stream of
terrorism I just don't see that at all I
had bill Richardson on the show last
night former UN Ambassador and he says
he goes all over Europe and he hears
very interesting things about the
president let's watch I go overseas all
the time you know what they ask me Laura
they say why is Perez
from leaving the American economy why is
he negative on the trans-pacific
partnership as it kills American job a
lot of NATO the president's not popular
mr. secretary is not a popular leader in
Obama was a rock star Clinton was the
rock star now we have this guy Trump and
Richardson and company the elites here
it's ruining our image around the world
well that's just not true
methey behavior or the conduct or the
decisions or the positions being taken
by the president united states are
ruining our image around the world I
think is is a massive overstatement the
reality is that the American people made
a conscious decision to put in the
presidency of the United States someone
who had never served in government
military or civilian I would have to
search through history to see if there's
ever been a president who had never
served in government now why did they do
that they did that because they wanted
someone who never served in government
and that's what we've got he does not
behave like an establishment politician
and that is hard for establishment
politicians and establishment media to
accept because it's it's not the normal
behavior of a seasoned politician who's
the president as part of it that these
elites both in media and politics were
so taken off-guard and so embarrassed by
the win of Trump because he took them on
personally he took them on substantively
he shattered all the perceptions of what
you how you have to run a campaign they
were all left flat-footed yeah and and
they all no one thought he'd win also I
mean that's embarrassing but the
American people decided they wanted to
roll the dice and put someone in that
office who came from a different
approach with a different approach and
and they got one and I was with a very
active Democrat today
wonderful classmate of mine from school
and and very much a Democrat and I said
well what do you think about all this he
said well he hasn't done anything wrong
and he hasn't he said what do you think
and I said well the most important job
of a senior executive is picking good
people and he has picked excellent
people the Supreme Court justice Gorsuch
the Vice President Madison defense his
cabinet is is it as good a cabinet it's
anything one of the two or three I
served him and it seems to me that he's
picking very good people sensible sound
thoughtful people parallels between the
treatment of Reagan and the treatment of
Trump in the media and by the elites
especially especially the European
elites I was in college I remember
Ronnie Reagan and oh yeah he's gonna
blow up the world the no nukes movement
it was it was a big push against Reagan
he was gonna blow up the world exactly
and he was the society the the elites in
the society were dismissive of Reagan
and didn't believe a movie actor and
bedtime with Bonzo could do the job and
he got in there and and that wonderful
warm sensible approach that he brought
to governance won over awful lot of
people in our country and he did a fine
job the elites never accepted him until
he was long gone now suddenly Reagan's
there